the hidden truth about quirks about the
world of mha and about the true nature
of one for all and all for one has just
been revealed Hoshi has been saving the
craziest and darkest twists for the end
of the manga and now they are coming at
us left and right so let's get into it
you guys know the drill if you enjoy our
mha videos and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like and
comment right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel awaken the true power of its
Quirk by hitting 2 million subscribers
do me a huge faor And subscribe right
now subscribing on YouTube is completely
free and we are so close to 2 million
finally this video will of course
contain M manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the previous chapter brought us
up to speed on what's happening on all
the other hero versus villain
battlefields across Japan and
practically everywhere you can think of
the heroes are winning a lot of the
action in the smaller battles just
happened offc screen but overall the
heroes have done a great job turning
things around and all for one's
carefully formulated master plan is
falling apart aleran and shigaraki are
basically the only two major villains
still left standing and even they don't
see eye to eye on how to proceed so yeah
all for one is having a tough time
adjusting to this current situation on
the ground and then there's the fact
that he is running out of time and he is
about to be rewound out of existence all
in all things are not very doobu for all
for one over on the main Battlefield deu
is of course still fighting shigaraki
and bakugo is still fighting all for
onean but all foran started getting
worried about how strong bakugo has
become and he decided that he doesn't
have any more time to waste he actually
tried running away from bakugo and
flying straight to shigaraki but Baku
cut up to him and prevented him from
reaching shigaraki this battle is
ongoing but the previous chapter ended
with all for one realizing why bakugo
makes him so mad even more mad than all
might it is because bakugo reminds him
so much of the second one for- all user
Kudo the man responsible for starting
the Rebellion against all for one in the
first place this leads us into the
latest chapter which finally reveals the
tragic backstory of both all for one and
his brother yoichi the first user of one
for all the name of this chapter is
Paranormal orphan and not going to lie
that's a pretty great name for like an
emo band in the mid 2000s before all
foran and yuichi were born their mother
was living on the streets and at one
point she seemingly developed some kind
of disease that produced a spike on her
left arm it's important to remember that
this is happening in the time before
quirks appeared so any odd mutation
would just be seen as some sort of
unnatural disease rather than a
paranormal ability at this time the
woman was pregnant with twins and as it
turns out all for one and his brother
yichi are actually twin brothers I
always assumed that yoichi was
considerably younger but that's only
because while they were in the womb all
for one was grabbing the majority of the
nutrients from their mother and so all
for one was born much bigger than his
tiny brother yoichi their mother gave
birth to the two twin boys by the river
and then afterwards she died it is worth
noting that when she died that weird
Spike on her arm disappeared and the
reason why will become clear very soon
the mother's corpse was then eaten by
rats but the two newborns were carried
to safety by the current of the river
and they survived now I don't know how
these newborns can survive being washed
away in the river and then washing up
somewhere else on their own but
presumably someone found them and helped
them you know how it is it's the power
of shown and logic now all of this
occurred like a year before the birth of
the luminescent baby the person who was
credited as the first official Quirk
user in the world this means that both
all for one and his brother developed
quirks before the first official Quirk
appeared but their quirks just weren't
noticed by anyone and it seems like
there were many other Quirk users that
emerged before the luminescent baby but
no one realized what these quirks really
were after the birth of the luminescent
baby the concept of quirks finally
started to catch on and more quirks
started to appear physical mutations
that before this time would have been
treated as illnesses were now recognized
for what they really were paranormal
abilities quirks mostly appeared in
newborns and children but they could
also appear in pretty much anyone who
still hadn't reached puberty the cause
of this phenomenon was the fact that a
new addition appeared within the human
genetic Factor although it still isn't
clear how this addition actually came
about as far back as the overhaul Arc we
learned that people speculated that
quirks were the result of a disease
spread by rodents that eventually
resulted in human genetic mutations but
it's also possible that quirks came
about as a result of some sort of human
experimentation perhaps government
experiments designed to give humans
special powers and turn them into super
soldiers the experiments might have
started out as something to be carried
out on a select few people but then
somehow the substance used to give
people quirks escaped CED the lab and
began to spread I am really interested
in how quirks came about in the first
place so I hope Hoshi does give us a
proper explanation instead of just vague
posting for about 400 chapters now
unsurprisingly when quirks first
appeared this caused Widespread Panic
among the general population those who
didn't have quirks got scared and
started claiming that people with quirks
were dangerous monsters rather than
normal human beings massive chaos ensued
and a few years after Quirk started to
appear anti- Quirk militias began
roaming the streets and attacking people
with quirks quirks were also known as
meta abilities paranormal abilities and
so on one of these groups actually came
across a young all for one and in that
moment all for one looked a lot like
little tenko shimura back when he was
roaming the streets in a State of Shock
after killing his own family The anti-
Quirk militia men felt bad for the
orphan but they knew that he was not
just an ordinary human he is a
paranormal orphan so they considered him
too dangerous to actually help him he
was already quote unquote infected and
so just like little tenko many years
later little Al for one was ignored and
left alone in the streets the militia
men turned to walk away from the boy but
before they can leave Al for one just
kills them all using a bunch of massive
spikes that suddenly emerge from his
body it seems that the spike that
appeared on the arm of all for one's
mother was actually her manifesting a
quirk and all for one stole it from her
before she died even as a newborn all
for one felt that the entire world was
his for the taking everything belonged
to him including his mother's squirk and
if you don't have anything to give him
then you're just a nuisance he will take
whatever he wants and if you stand in
his way he will destroy you this also
confirms that all for one manifested his
Quirk stealing Quirk as a newborn
meaning that he was a cork user long
before the luminescent baby as the years
pass all for one starts wrecking havoc
on the streets of Japan we see him
attacking people left and right and
presumably taking their quirks and
everything else that he desires from
them little yoichi is also there and he
is trying to stop his brother from
hurting other people yoichi was much
smaller and weaker than his brother and
at this time he didn't know he had a
quirk but he still tried to stand up to
his brother even as a toddler
nevertheless we see all for one just
kicking yoichi away and moving on clear
uninterested in yoichi's opinions
because yoichi was weak and seemingly
quirkless he couldn't really give all
for one anything that he desired
normally this would lead Al foran to
Simply discard the person in question
but because yichi was Al foran's brother
he saw him as one of the things that
belonged to him so he kept yoichi almost
as a sort of possession rather than a
family member that he loved and cared
for we then see a scene from a few years
later a scene in which yichi is reading
the famous famous comic Captain Hero
yoichi idolizes Captain Hero and he
wants to be just like him he wants to
become a hero who helps people which is
kind of the opposite of what his older
brother has been doing however yoichi
still believes that deep inside all for
one can be good in some ways all for one
protected his much smaller and weaker
brother which is what allowed yoichi to
survive this long so maybe just maybe
there is some goodness inside all for
one meanwhile over the years the famous
luminescent baby had become some sort of
Peace activist who tried to end the
chaos and create a world where people
with quirks and without them could live
in harmony the luminescent baby gathered
like 10 million followers for his
movement and this made all for one angry
because to him the luminescent baby was
a fraud the baby's popularity came from
the false belief that he was the first
person to ever manifest a quirk but
dozens of people with quirks were born
before the luminescent baby including
all for one and yichi all for one feels
that the baby has no right to command so
many supporters based on this false idea
of him being the first Quirk user so all
for one tracked him down and stole his
Quirk if you guys recall back when all
for one was fighting all might he
literally started glowing at one point
and I said that this looks like the
luminescent baby's Quirk I started
speculating about all for one
potentially stealing this Quirk at some
point in the past since we know that
he's been around for a very long long
time and that speculation was seemingly
confirmed now and I think it makes a lot
of sense all for one is definitely the
type of guy who would steal the world's
most famous Quirk and The Quirk that
people believed was the first quirk in
the world it is the perfect Quirk to add
to his collection as part of his mission
to flex on everyone and become the Demon
Lord when yuichi asks his brother why he
has to do such terrible things all one
explains that it's a lot like those
Comics that yoichi likes to read just as
yii dreams of being a hero all for one
dreams of becoming the ultimate Demon
Lord he wants to create a world where
everything belongs to him where
everything exists just for his own sake
and where everyone must obey his rule or
face the consequences but then we see
the moment that the second user of one
forall Kudo shows up and ruins all for
one's plan this is happening years later
when yichi and aleran are already adults
soon after aleran gave his brother a
court the stockpiling Quirk that
eventually evolved into one for all
yuichi was released from his captivity
by Kudo and the other Rebels this
infuriated all for one because yichi was
one of his things one of his possessions
and no one had the right to take that
away what's more no one had the right to
rebel against the Demon Lord because the
world was his for the taking and
resisting his will was unacceptable it
seems that all for one either killed his
brother or at least cut off his hand as
he was making his Escape with Kudo but
whatever ultimately happened to yoichi
we know that he managed to transfer one
for all to Kudo before he died and even
though this happened so long ago this
was the beginning of the end of all for
one's reign of terror this was the first
time when he couldn't get exactly what
he wanted he lost his brother and he
lost the Quirk that he himself created
one for all he would spend over a
hundred years trying to get this Quirk
back but it continued to evade him and
it could continued to grow and evolve
over the generations until it finally
made its way to deu and now in the
present time it looks like Al for one is
finally about to be defeated things have
come full circle the entitled and greedy
child all for one is back due to the
effects of rewind but the way things
stand it looks like he won't reach
shigaraki in time and he may be rewound
out of existence any second the truth
about quirks and the world of mha is a
lot darker than we thought and
definitely a lot darker than the early
chapters and episodes of the story made
it out to be I mean what happened to
yoichi and all for one's mother was just
terrible what is the full ugly truth
about the rise of quirks and its
aftermath and how will that affect the
final battle between Deku and shigaraki
in the modern world we already know the
many parallels between deu and all might
and we now see some pretty clear
parallels between Yang for one
and young tenko shimura how will all of
this come into play in the final
showdown let me know what you guys think
down in the comments below if you're
looking for more epic mha content to
watch right now don't ignore my full mha
playlist link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like to let me know and if
you want to help this channel awaken the
full power of its Quirk do me a huge
favor and subscribe right now we are so
close to 2 million subscribers is